In the 1930s, the Dassler brothers' sport shoe company in Bavaria...
...made the most kick-ass athletic shoes in all the land.
The company even gave Jesse Owens a pair of shoes to compete in the 36th Olympics.
When Jesse won, the brothers' shoes blew up.
But all of that success was not good for their relationship.
Tensions flared.
Some say there was stealing, affairs, resentment...
...and after World War II, the brothers were so out of step,...
...they eventually ended the company.
In 1949, Adolf or Adi Dassler formed Adidas, a play on his nickname.
Rudolf Dassler started Puma because, well, that name is awesome.
The brothers sued each other many, many times over the years...
...over all sorts of design and trademark issues,...
...costing each other a fortune in lawyers and suits.
Their two factories built in the same Bavarian village of Herzogenaurach...
...polarized the community with local people picking sides by picking shoes.
The brothers died two years apart.
They are buried at opposite ends of the village graveyard,...
...proof that even in death there remained a great bitter divide between them.
And so it was for decades until 2009.
Employees of Adidas and Puma...
...in the village where the two companies still have their headquarters came together...
...and played a friendly soccer match...
...and started the process of healing decades of enmity...
...and began a new era of love and shoes.